[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
make me
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
sleep
[Music]
me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
is
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's going on you guys
gaming addict here lord addict man we we
doing another
attic show got my co-host with me the
this is the attic show for those of you
that don't know i don't know why you'd
be here if you don't know uh where we
talk about the past present and future
of gaming as i said i got my co-host
with me hustle and motivate what you
doing hustle
a lot of work behind me as you see just
getting my setup and stuff together
and i didn't want to look like a
complete slob today so the green screen
will be up partially of the way part of
the way uh y'all see different little
things behind me
a lot of stuff is in the motion a lot of
stuff's in the work ethic you already
know that but um outside of that man i'm
good i i feel good i i feel good about
today's topics the you know the the news
like you know we we finally saw
something in reference to star phil but
we'll get to that soon enough um how
about yourself man how are you doing man
i ain't gonna lie i just woke up like
oh like an hour ago
i was sitting there man i was like man
it's already five
like
it was it's a rough moment man but i'm
up now i'm up now partially partially
i'm up now partially what have you been
playing hustle i i'm kind of curious
what you've been playing oh i got a
really good answer for that i have been
uh continuing my journey in eldon ring i
have been doing that um
i played and beat disney's aladdin on
the super nintendo um if you have not
played it uh it's one of capcom's finest
creations and i encourage you to do so
just go ahead and emulate it i'm not
going to say your way because i don't
want to get me and myself or the squad
caught up but you can just go ahead and
emulate it it's a cool game man the
super nintendo version and the second
genesis version because it's two
different versions made by two different
companies and i feel like they offer you
know different perspectives on each one
um
i'm not sure if you're from familiar
with richard branson
no he is he is the owner of
virgin um have you you remember back in
the day they used to have like virgin
mobile cell phones virgin mobile record
label and stuff like that
yeah he
owns that i'm not sure if he owned the
company i mean he owns a company that
made it but i'm not sure what he had to
do with gaming back then but like he
owned like everything that boy he got a
private island no cap he really got a
private island private ireland he he
literally had a private island it's on
mtv cribs you can look that up but
anyway anyway so a lot of that stuff was
in y'all i'm in my retro bag man so i
went back and i played and then i beat
it but it's fun though it's super fun
you know that
you know i i don't really do the metro
stuff and you know that
yeah yeah but i i hope you enjoyed it
oh for sure i used to i love that game
as a kid i ran back through it and yes
it's too much fun i promise you it was
too much fun
yeah i've been uh playing a lot of
triangle strategy i think i'm coming
close to the end of that game like
people were kind of like questioning the
fact that i said it's probably not worth
the uh the money that you invest into it
like look i'm not saying the game the
game's a great game it's just
that's still 60 bucks and if you look at
that like i feel like
it does what it does well
but i do feel like there is better games
to do what it does you know what i'm
saying like
and those games are half the price
that's why i was like you know if you
like these type of games
buy it
don't listen to me and buy it i don't
care
like it's just like
the things that triangle strategy does
they do well
but uh the felsil that's an example like
stuff that i bought this because i
wanted like kind of a spiritual
successor to
final fantasy tactics
and
the key components to tactics
just it's just not in this game
and
it's it's sad and i'm not saying that i
didn't i'm not enjoying the time i
playing i think it's got a really good
story but you know for for those of you
that you know want the the break break
down you know i'll probably have the
review up maybe friday
i don't know yet
it just depends on what happens man
hey good question from uh don shariko i
i killed your name my fault from don in
the chat it's just better than the
octopad traveler because i think you
were big on that one um
i might have to say octopass better
maybe not by much
what i liked about octopath is just the
the way the combat was done now strategy
is good too like i can't really say
one's better than the other they're both
pretty solid expansions that uh solid
games that to be fair with you
considering the same studio made them
both
uh
this studio got a good track record of
me you know what i'm saying
it's just
maybe it's just because it's on the
switch also like the performance isn't
really there it it really isn't
we learned your lesson yet
wait is this game is it a nintendo
switch exclusive or is this coming oh no
sorry i'm starting to get annoyed when i
see exclusive nintendo games i'm not
gonna lie
if it's not mario zelda yoshi or one of
those one of the first parties i get it
i get it
i mean classic ips i'm getting annoyed
in general with that stuff so okay
channel updates uh i i have started
my progression when it comes to
the channel art that well the the
podcast art uh you guys gonna have to
bear with me there because
uh it takes a minute to make this gotta
go back forward back and forth back and
forth uh but hopefully that will be done
here in the next couple weeks hopefully
maybe the end of next month i don't know
because
i'm not like one of those people because
i go through uh
topics or two pictures or whatever the
website's called it's just pretty much
where you contract individual people to
work on artwork
and i don't like it i i will send them
back to the drawing board it's like oh
[ __ ] it's like i paid for revisions
you're gonna rev you're gonna revise
that
uh but but a lot of the people on there
they're pretty good they're pretty good
all right and
as far as
today people may know that we're doing
this on a wednesday i don't know why but
i i kind of like doing this towards the
end of the week and not necessarily i
mean it's not really towards the end of
the week it's just a day difference but
i feel like
it i maybe it's because i do so much
on sunday because i'm a five hour
podcast
that's
on average that's three addict shows i
do every sunday
[Music]
but if you know what it is though like
we we do it we'll do this in the middle
of the week this will give you time to
like really just chill same thing
playing with me like cuz i'm in the chat
with y'all and i don't know how you like
was pulling off the like quick
turnaround it's like
podcast on sunday and then tuesday five
o'clock you here with me man so i mean
my head go off to you yeah so
i couldn't do it my my question to the
chat
people in here
is
would wednesday be a good day for some
of you in the chat well obviously at the
end of the day
if me and hustle want this to be on a
wednesday we gonna make it wednesday but
i do want you
i do want your guys's opinion on the
matter uh if wednesday at five to six
i'm pretty sure five
is gonna be the go-to but five the only
reason i didn't do later on a tuesday
is because rdx is at nine
or eight
one of those hours
and
i know we can't compete with that you
know
because i don't slow down slow down
we can compete with anybody slow down
yeah okay
i'm being realistic okay
because i'm sorry
i'm sure some of our we got a lot of
cross going between both but yeah if you
notice people don't really straight uh
do podcasts like midday like the
five-ish time like people don't really
do that
uh so you know usually
regardless what day it is i think
wednesday would be a good time i do i
think wednesday is enough days after iop
uh i my idea would be thursday because
that's the day i'm off but i don't want
to do thursday there's just too much
stuff going down on thursday wednesday
so why not that's somebody said that's
even better like it i don't know well
it's really bothering me so much
a lot of updates happen monday or
tuesday a lot of updates happen oh yeah
so i i like to be on that wednesday
thing
uh that wednesday that way we can break
down what happened the past couple days
it would be
you know i try to keep the topics i
don't know if people notice i try to
keep the topics a little bit different
when it comes to
iop like i try my hardest
not to have too many people
uh not to have too many
cross topics i try uh sometimes i fail
at it because it's it's kind of hard
but all right so let's let's you guys go
ahead uh so someone said wednesdays is
good uh is great day not too many shows
midweek i agree with you uh someone said
uh are you reviewing tunic i'm pretty
sure that game's out right now and uh
that it is all right yo i wanted to play
it
i'm glad they brought that up i wanted
to playable for the podcast
so i went and i saw like the little
tweet from nebu neighbor and neville you
know he is i saw the tweet so i said let
me let me hop on um game pass real quick
cause they said it was on pc as well so
i'm like okay bet i'm already there
i couldn't like look it up when i went
to hit the search bar and put the game
in it wasn't like hey this game isn't
under ea or something like that so i'm
like well i must be doing something
wrong i saw um so one of my homies so
i'm not gonna mention because i want
well it's out today i saw erica playing
it so i'm like with damn how she played
before i could play it but
i'm not sure and i didn't want to spend
because i think that game's 30 dollars i
didn't want to spend the 30 on it i said
nah i said i already got game pass and
that's kind of what i have that for so
i want to play it though i definitely
want to play i'm going to try to play it
after we're finished here
i'm going to do my best i'm going to do
my damn this man
i gotta
i do want to
review tunic
but i got to finish this triangle
strategy i put so many hours in this
thing i'm like 30 some hours in this
game
and like
i one thing i will say about the game
it's got a good narrative but i feel
like the narrative is just hitting me in
the head over and over again they're
like you got to watch like five
different cutscenes or story narrative
focus driven stuff to get into one
combat
and sometimes i feel like that i'll
literally be on my phone for because
what i do is they have like an auto
thing where they continuously go through
the dialogue so i'll go through the
dialogue get on my phone and i feel like
i i i've read like 18 posts on twitter
like
there's just an absurd amount of
dialogue before you actually get into
the gameplay it doesn't necessarily mean
it's a bad thing it's just i do feel
like you know tactics did a good job
where they were tearing in there though
telling a narrative and you were
fighting with that narrative
but i feel like on this game it's like
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna hit
you in the head over and over again with
narrative and then we're going to
do an actual mission sometimes there's
only like maybe two three fights in a
chapter
like a whole chapter two or three
[ __ ]
so i mean it's not the biggest end of
the deal but you know
it is what it is so let's let's go jump
jump straight into a hustle
all right
we're going to go ahead and start with
the games of 2022 because i feel like
the star field and the the perfect dart
is going to take up the majority of the
show
uh clearly there's been going on all
along about perfect art we'll get into
that and we're going to turn that into a
little bit with
xbox first party studios in general
now
games of 2022 hustle what are some of
the games of 2022 that you're excited
for because keep in mind i feel like the
biggest games
were were coming out in february
like the biggest games for this year
were coming out in february but besides
those games what
what is remaining that has you excited
well there was one game that i was
really anticipating as you all know
uh if you deal with the meta of hustle
it's shredder's revenge i do love beat
em ups so when that drops it's supposed
to drop later on this year we haven't
really seen anything from it outside of
a trailer i think at the end of last
year might have been a state of play or
something they didn't have a date but
they just had the release year which was
2022.
i'm also looking forward to the ninja
turtles kyle bunga collection now i i
can't reach it and i can't get it right
now but uh turtles in time is on that
list and i think it's the arcade version
of that game it's actually 13 different
games on that list and um
i look forward to running through them
like running through them all like for
me um it's going to be on like 13 games
for 40 of them
yup for 40 dollars and i'm gonna make
sure i top it day one i think that uh
that's pretty fair 13 games for 40.
i think that's a fair price
especially when you got when you got at
least three classics on that list man i
don't really think you can go wrong with
that um but i am looking forward to that
god of war we don't know if that's
coming out this year uh
i don't want to say no i don't want to
say no just yet but i'm going to tell
you no it's not coming out this year i i
got i got a feeling tonight man because
we ain't heard
a peep out nobody over there wearing
curry ball look with her no no
to my knowledge isn't the game director
of this game i know no no i know it's
another gentleman whose name escapes me
at the moment but i kind of follow a few
of them i haven't really heard anything
from them so
you know
i kind of want that to come out this
year um
horizon i have not played horizon yet i
am going i do plan on buying horizon
probably like in april or something when
i'm finished up with
when i try to finish up with uh that
sakura when i try to finish up with a
elden ring which i'm actually having a
blast with i think i'm actually trying
to like earn understand it a little bit
um i had um ricky ricardo 430 that's my
boy from the troubleshooters he was kind
of walking me through it on one of my
last live streams he was like nah i said
hustle you do this she kind of showed me
where certain upgrades were and
everything i got this i got this fly
little gold helmet too man i got i got
like a big sword that you got to use two
hands to swing with it's
it's a whole thing it's a i got like a
big shield i picked up a big shield off
one of the enemies so that's that's the
whole thing so i'm having fun with that
um
i'm not really sure
what else is supposed to come out this
year aside from like starfield
i'm not because i don't as far as like
the big releases
i couldn't really tell you what else is
coming out that i'm looking forward to
is it anything on your list at it
because i pretty much like you know for
me it's shredder's revenge oh wait wait
wait one last thing one last thing river
city girls too that's another one that
i'm definitely looking forward to that's
what i think that's supposed to come out
this year as well so i'm definitely
looking forward to that too
i think
i'm definitely looking forward to games
coming out
um star fields one of them i'm not the
big forza fan
uh but i do know forza motorsports
probably going to come out this year
now
as far as that game's going to be like
good
that's that that's debatable they don't
normally miss too too much you know they
might
uh
j what's our world are looking for they
might miss step but they don't really
miss
uh i'm not really
i i don't mind the fours or rising games
but when it comes to like the
simulations that's definitely a no-go
for me complete no go
but
i don't know i'm kind of curious
to
to see the games that gets announced
like
this year at e3 i think well not e3 but
whatever the e3 equivalent is that's
what obviously
i i
i definitely looking forward to star
field and you know we'll get more into
starfield later but
probably there's other games that
microsoft's making and sony's making
that i just want more information on in
general and it's not necessarily
they have to come out this year i just
want to know more about them like i
would like
to see fable
in some way shape or form i don't know
if we're going to see fable anytime soon
but i would like to see fable
uh so you know it it is i but starfield
don't get me wrong starfield's
definitely going to be that game i do
feel like
you know starfield's going to surprise
some people
now you know we'll get into exactly what
was said uh today on um
uh
they they did a video and we'll get to
that here in a minute but you know they
kind of broke down a little bit more
stuff that in terms of what's going on
with starfield
and i first off you know let's just go
ahead and move to the starfield topic
how do you feel about starfish is that
something that you're excited about also
yeah particularly and i'll tell you why
because if it is what i think it is and
this is what we lead to believe it is if
they say it's fall out in space then man
i mean i'm always
i'm like look as far as but there's the
games especially the rpgs i ain't too
too big into them i'm kind of glad that
y'all finally getting something that's
highly anticipated you know kind of like
sought after um because you guys are
coming off of halo infinite which
i mean
we can talk about that at another time
but it's not really doing too well so
you guys have something else to play
later on this year
i hope it's good for your sake i hope
it's not
the typical buggy but that's the game
because fallout 76 started off
super bad
we all know that it started off super
bad so i hope it's not
i hope it's not bad and by this being a
new ip man i i always like want the best
for new ips so i just may try it but
that's that's not something that i'm
super big on like
you would be the uh aficionado and on
this side of things over here as far as
you know as far as we're concerned so
could you tell me what you think about
it
i'm ex there's a couple things i'm
nervous about when it comes to star
field
a couple times when they brought out
what starfield is
they've used language that i generally
hate people using like uh for example
create your own story i no i i'm paying
60 70 dollars for you to create me a
story not for me to create me a story my
imagination ain't like that fam if i was
like that i'd go play minecraft where
i'd legitly create my own story you
create me a story that i could consume
stop having me do all the work
uh you so when they say stuff like that
and i know
that's like pr talk and sometimes it's
not exactly what they say
but i can't stand when people say that i
really can i'm like dude ain't nobody
trying to hear that
we we we trying to have a cohesive story
told to us we ain't trying to have you
tell us one that's why i'm always big on
the elden ring uh you know
it's like look like i love eldon ring um
i love but i've personally in to this
day now look i will admit that there uh
after playing a lot more elder ring that
there is a lot more lore building in
that game than i originally thought
uh because obviously i'm further in the
game but i still feel like they can
improve on that world building uh just
like you know i i just like
i like things to make sense i like
things to connect with each other i like
foreshadowing events or people in the
future
in the beginning of the game you know
what i'm saying like that's what i like
to do and evidently does a good job on
that uh in terms of you know demigods
and you come across them and then you
have to fight them they do a pretty
decent job at that but when it comes to
starfield that's what i'm most worried
about and i think you know
people like to compare this game to
uh what's that what's that that game
playstation published about the uh no
man's sky they like to like
compare the the exploration of no man's
sky
i hope to god that's not true
like you have no idea man
like
i want
if anything i would like a true open
world but if that's not possible because
of the direction that this game went to
i'm okay with a really good immersive
hub world where like you go to something
and uh you go to your ship and your ship
is what teleports you or transports you
to every evening uh to every era or
every planet you know what i'm saying
like kind of like the outer worlds i'm
okay with something like that it's just
like
don't have first i don't want to fly a
ship
i don't i don't care
like if they had me fly a ship i'm gonna
be shitty
like i'm gonna be upset the whole time i
fly that thing because i ain't trying to
fly no [ __ ]
i want someone else to fly the ship as
long as it's not like uh insomniac with
the ratchet and clan games i mean i
think you know it should be cool like
if if the controls aren't bad then i
think that should be that should be like
a fun time if you are
running around you got some missions in
space um halo reach i'm sure you played
and beat that one there's a section
where you are in a ship and you kind of
flying around and you're going after the
covenant i think i can't remember i know
i played media but
that that stuff like that was pretty fun
for me um i said i don't know so i
disagree i think if i think if it's
pulled off right i wouldn't mind flying
in the ship you don't get um like motion
sick do you
kinda and then it just some games do it
better than others if that makes sense
like i've never had full-blown
motion sickness where i have to turn the
game off you know what i'm saying uh but
there's some oculus stuff that will make
me slightly motion sick but i wouldn't
go as far to say like
i can't i gotta turn this off right now
so we gotta find our super chat from
dawn otaku i died a game with 150 000
lines of dialogue will make you create
your own story you got you're on
something there man all i'm saying is
they better tell me a story they if not
better people that that's it's like i
said that that's like the elder ring
thing like i brought up earlier like i
hate those games or like you got to go
and fetch something that's why we roast
the destiny the way we did
because they made you go to another
outlet to
research the story of the game like
people was like oh addicts you know you
could go on the internet and you could
easily find youtube channels that
explain the elder and reading lore
none of that nonsense how about the game
explains to me the eldon read lore and
that they do a good job you know that we
could really talk about odin ring
because i feel like the internet won't
shut up about ordinary which deserving
it does because it's an amazing game but
you know we're gonna let's let's get
back to the story phil
i feel like
star field has the potential
to be great
but we just got to see
how they execute a new vision
sometimes when you're making a new game
you
try things that you necessarily
shouldn't have tried because you want to
innervate it and you end up ruining it
now i'm not saying that's going to be
star filled pretty sure
todd howard and that team
you know that
they're they hitting good ratios like
people want to blame
them all the time for fallout 76
the studio making starfield did not make
fallout 76
i don't know why
huh okay educate educate me there
because i thought it was i thought there
were one in the same so yeah well
bethesda software studios has a couple
studios under that umbrella
and one of them is bethesda software
austin they made fallout 76.
uh now bethesda's software studios like
the core team the one that made fallout
skyrim the ones that makes the the heavy
hitters
they did help with the game as far as
like animations and stuff to get it out
the door but they didn't make that game
and you know
fallout 76
they should be ashamed of how that game
launched like
i will agree that fallout at one point
in time
had that
i could do no wrong clout you know what
i'm saying well any uh bethesda game
they had that i could pop out any game
any it doesn't matter how buggy it is
and i'm gonna be grace for it i don't
think that's the case this time
i think now i i do think they come out
there with a heavy hitter if they
somehow dethrone elden ring as my game
of the year they've won i've been the
need of them all just that by themselves
because eldon ring
is a fantastic game and people getting
on me because i say eldon ring is my
game of the year look
until someone makes something that's
better elder elder ring is one of the
best games i've played in probably a
decade
it and it's just like
wait hold on hold on best best game
period or best souls game best game
period
okay
i can't
i can't really think of games that's
better than very well like it would have
to be like the skyrims and you know i i
wasn't the biggest fan in the witcher
maybe saying i wasn't the biggest fan of
the witcher isn't fair i just couldn't
never gave the witcher a complete 100
shot
when i think of something that's on the
quality of elden ring it's those type of
games
and
fallout
bethesda software studios people keep
acting like they they've made nothing
but
but misses it's like no they they've
made
they're probably the studio that has the
most game of the years out of all the
studios
because they i they got game of the year
for fallout 3 they got game of the year
for skyrim i'm pretty sure they got game
of the year for morrowind
they they they got runner up for fall at
four and i think they got runner up for
fallout new vegas i think i think i
can't remember who beat them that year
but they might have got runner their
games is neither runner-up or game of
the year every single one of them
there's not been one game that has them
type of
you know criteria and i get it
their their greatest hits
was like
15 years ago
well 12 12 years ago but
where is that
i just
i feel like if it would like rockstar
gets so much slack
for taking seven to eight years to make
a game making one game a generation
but
bethesda
they're they're told they can't have
that kind of time you know what i'm
saying
like it's just like and i'm not trying
to compare the two they're two different
games
but it's just like
bethesda sure i might have been a little
disappointed how they did some of the
things in fall and fallout 4.
but fallout 4 was still a very
successful game it was a very polished
game sure there's a little bit of
glitches in the beginning of the game
but i like a lot of the things they did
in fallout i just felt like they could
have improved some of the aspects of
fallout uh so
where
okay let's talk about the star-filled
hype
because a lot of people
a lot of people coming at me today over
this
do you think
it's logical for a team for for fans
and be honest with you because clearly
you know where i stand i
uh you you you could have your opinion
even if i disagree
do you think it's logical
for
fans to be hyped for a game
that we've seen almost nothing on in
terms of gameplay
if you're familiar with that studio then
then yeah like the second rock star
shows grand theft auto six in my opinion
it's through the roof i'm i'm going to
the mall with it because i know what to
expect like the moon you're going to the
moon i'm going to that mean i'm i'm
taking off with it i'm you know blasting
off man because i know what to expect
from rockstar at that point you know
what to expect from bethesda a lot
better than i do
so therefore with the fallout series
skyrim so on and so forth you already
know what to expect from them and if
we're hearing comparisons rumbling
around of what this game is supposed to
be then you can be excited that's the
thing hey look you can be excited i got
a theory that you can kind of be excited
for whatever you want to be if something
looks interesting to you there's nothing
for you to be
unless you get like a whole uh
what game is that it's over there on
xbox i cannot think of the name of the
game it's like for me it's a franchise
it's
it's the third one in the franchise
attic and i cannot think of it for the
life of me but it's um
it's the xbox first party studio and i
cannot think of the name of iceland
huh wasteland no not wasteland not
wasteland this oh my god i had the
thought in my hand and i had the name of
the game in my the franchise in my head
but i said they're on the third one
they're on the third one yes
in the third game in the series hey it's
um uh chat put put put some guesses man
let's play a game can we guess what's in
hustle's mind because i have no no
talking about
well oh well i would like to offer y'all
some money for a prize but i can't
afford that either um
it's not wasteland i think it starts
with i think it does start with a w
uh
i can't think of the name of it but it's
it's another like well it's not four is
that because they're on five
now four it's uh
it's
not cracked it's not crackdown either
okay there you go thank you thank you i
said start with a w instead of the k
so when you have a that i almost forgot
my oh my god what's wrong with me what's
wrong with me i almost forgot my point
no when you when you have something like
that the way
the cinematics won't necessarily look
like the gameplay
then you feel like you're bamboozled and
it's like a
a whole situation like that i get but
you know what you expect when you play
wasteland you know what you expect when
you play a skyrim or in my case a grand
theft auto like we know we getting when
it come to that so i mean for people to
say oh you can't be hyped about it it's
um
i feel like that's like a foolish thing
to say i feel like i think it's i think
it's odd that people can even
thing is i always think it's odd when
people try to rain on other people's
parade but
look i'm not gonna sit up here and throw
stones and hide in my hand or those
stones living in a glass house i'm sure
i've done that before too but
i just let people enjoy what they enjoy
if they hate for it go ahead man go nuts
i feel like we should be able to hype up
any damn thing we want to like look
we should regardless if the game was up
to the hype
it shouldn't take away the fact that
you're hyped for it
like
look if anything
i've always been one of those people you
hype up that game as much as you want
but if that game comes out and it
doesn't live up to your expectations
you better not you better not defend
that damn game
oh you you better you better drop all
the fives of hell on that game if it's
if it's not living up your expectation
kingdom hearts three
i was so excited for it
game came out
disappointed
fallout 4 i was so excited for it game
came out disappointed now
is that really a test of the quality of
the game itself or is that just a test
of maybe i over hyped something in my
mind and the game couldn't realistically
live up to that expectation
maybe it's the latter who knows but as
far as to say that i can't have those
kind of expectations
it's just ridiculous like
i've always been one of those people
like look look at something like when it
comes to
um gran turismo 7.
you know it's
if i can speak out against
kingdom hearts
then people should be able to speak out
against grand trisma for what they've
done
putting microtransactions into a game
post review
if you look at if you look at
the graphics of that game they're not
that impressive they're just not i
that's just my opinion i'm not really
hold on hold on i gotta slow you down on
that second part um you sure that's
that's gran charisma those games always
look great look that's a racing game i
will say
that the game looks good in other
scenarios and it doesn't look good in
other scenarios i feel like the game is
very inconsistent in the way it looks
and if you're inconsistent in the way it
looks then i feel like
you automatically get hit because
there's a difference
i'd rather a game look shitty
than look inconsistent to how i'm
playing if you feel like you're playing
a ps5 game at some times in a ps3 game
at other times then that
that looks that that's a bad look let's
be real here let's keep it a hundred
hustle um damn i see i didn't see i
haven't played that game i've only known
one what's wrong with you you ain't
messing with me you play that game well
well jay got shout out to jay guy he
know who he is and uh y'all y'all we all
know hallhead in here he's another like
i i saw hard him uh playing the stream
this game it looked fine to me but
you know hold on hold on i got a
question do you does anybody in that
chair or edit do you know who made a
grant who made this new grand charisma
was it politically digital
politically digital who that is i could
google it but i don't i kind of don't
want to
do all that if it is polyphony if it is
politically digital then this isn't the
first time that they've done like the
micro transactions thing i want to take
y'all all the way back
way back to 2008 i do believe whenever
the ps or 2006 whenever the ps3 dropped
and whenever um that version of grant
turismo
i think in order for you to buy
everything in that game like you had to
spend like four thousand dollars oh
that's right for this
yeah remember when evolve came out and
it had like
500 worth of microtransactions that day
came out
and those are good old days i actually
liked evolve too i was really upset that
game failed
i passed on that joint i saw i wasn't
you know it's crazy i'm a big old
hypocrite for that too but like when i
saw i passed on that but i wanted to
play on friday the 13th when that's good
that was a good game yeah it's fine
friday 13 minutes super fun but i never
played evolved man by the time i really
wanted to come around to it that thing
was in the grave over and done with
sadly so yeah you know
it had a good concept and i don't even
think they executed it poorly
it's just i feel like they didn't really
think about that game in the long term
you know what i'm saying like
it was it was a fun game i really
enjoyed that i actually bought that game
oh my god my condolences
i really should hit up microsoft ask for
some money back
oh my god
i can't even play the game
you know not to go off topic a little
bit do you think when you play a game
and they turn off the servers you
like and we're not even talking about
like 10 years of turning off the servers
that they turn off the servers in a
couple years like two to three
and it's like a mainly an online
infrastructure type of game do you think
you're entitled to a refund at that
point
one one thousand percent because it's
not like they're cutting off the servers
like
10 years later the way you pretty much
got everything you don't get out of it
now that's over that's over like and
that's i mean look if that game didn't
perform well so i understood why they
turned it off like i get it
but that's kind of criminal at that
point like yo i mean i don't know see i
don't know how much it costs to keep a
server on either so let me let me i want
to slow slow myself up a little bit
because that may cost a certain amount
of money that i'm not aware of but if it
does cost something like at least maybe
if you don't get all the money back get
get like a partial refund give some type
of store credit some
something because something got to be
done because you can't just be on 2016
and then 2018 it's over the dream is
over everything is going like you can't
like that's two years like what do you
get out of you get out of that two years
excuse me you know what game that i
really let me get this two dollar super
trout from space
dovahkiing
todd howard and his a team are a world
class
look
i do think that they're very
experienced developers and i think they
make classic games
but i'm really hoping that
that they take star field
i personally this is okay okay okay
let's play game is attic bugging hustle
all right it i personally feel like
starfield was supposed to come out last
year
but when they but when microsoft bought
bethesda
microsoft's like look
go back into the closet
go ahead and
restructure
the foundation of the game a little bit
make sure everything is is fine too i
don't want no issues with this game i
don't want the world bug fezda to happen
anywhere in this game
and
make it next gen only
and i think that
microsoft gave them the time for that
and they delayed the game a year to give
them the time to make sure that the bugs
weren't there to make sure that you know
regardless i don't know if the game was
always going to be a next gen only game
i'm glad it's only uh will current gen
at this point but
i'm glad they gave them that time
because we need more studios willing to
do stuff like that
to give developers time to make the game
they want we've seen it with
wasteland microsoft gave them a little
bit more time game was better because of
it psychonauts microsoft gave them more
time game was better than because of it
i feel like if we stop rushing
development a lot of the issues in the
industry will go away overnight the
review process will probably go away
overnight because now you're not rushing
games out the door and having to do day
one patches up to the last minute you
can actually give develop reviewers
the time they need to review a game
properly with the proper patches
but um
i think you bugger i think you're
bugging you not only
yeah i think so max i think bethesda
wanted to put this out as soon as
possible following up on um follow after
fallout 76 i think that was the last
getting released before this when you
correct me from wrong
if they wanted to come off of that
if even though that game has been
improved and everything but if they
wanted to come off of that to say l for
all intents and purposes
they wanted to drop the new thing
i i guarantee they wanted to drop the
new thing regardless if it was on ps4 uh
xbox one and in these new consoles
yo they'll put it anywhere we heard todd
howard say hey listen
we're gonna keep putting out the same
games because y'all keep buying them so
that if that don't sound like a man who
will buy this money to me that he
definitely would have dropped it on both
of them consoles and as far as making it
series s and x
well as far as current gen exclusive
with with the xbox and pc
now he would be able to drop that jordan
everywhere he would have put it
everywhere he could have possibly played
i actually disagree on that because i
feel like
the only reason to push
a game out sooner
than you want to
is i feel like
the only reason to do that is just
because you simply
you don't
you need the money you know people are
pushing for
investors are pushing for it
you need that money that flow you need
to improve to investors why they spend
so much money into it but i feel like th
most developers if they had more time
they would take more time
and the reason i feel like
they might have gave them more time is
because
microsoft
last year was halo
i don't
do you think starfield coming out last
year would have would have hurt halo
absolutely yes one thousand percent
that's what i really felt like
when it comes to star field and bethesda
i feel like they're like look
bethesda we don't necessarily need you
this year
like you we we we need a side piece next
year
so
but
we know that you can make this game
better a year
from last year you you probably have a a
less buggy game because i already know
there's going to be some form of bugs i
already know this like oh it just
depends on how
much the bugs are
and i i don't think i think this game is
going to come out relatively
flawless i i because they've had an
extra year
i feel like
maybe some features was added to the
game that
they would have naturally worked on but
now they're actually putting in the full
retail game
and that that's why
i'm confident
with them like it are they perfect no no
developers perfect they they've messed
up on a lot of things you know the thing
i want to go over right now with you
is
they actually talked about
all right let's
you don't play a lot of uh bethesda
gangs but i
they used to have a huge formula in
making bethesda format games like you
would make your own character make the
build that you want the character and
you would go from there but i feel like
ever since i would say skyrim they kind
of went away from that a little bit
and i feel like every game it gets worse
over the previous one you know what i'm
saying
like in fallout 4 you didn't even get to
put you didn't even get to make your
character it was pretty much like an
all-around character
you got perks
but it wasn't it wasn't the same you
know what i'm saying from like fallout
new vegas fallout 3.
and
i felt like
the dialogue system the persuasive
system was was wasn't the greatest in
fallout 4 either
so but
they made that video
made for wanderers and they pretty much
like go over a little bit of the
companions you have for the game
uh they got a lot of things let me get
this two dollar superchat real quick two
dollars to retract from flame
i bought battleborn
don't feel bad at it
guess what flame so did i
so
that was like overwatch real quick that
was like overwatch right
yeah that was like the overwatch yeah
they messed up with that man
overwatch what's funny is at that time i
don't think they really
knew what the kind of beast overwatch
would be
i mean
they knew they had something but it's
like eldon ring
they knew they have a game but did they
think it would be what it turned out to
be you know what i'm saying
so
all right so the
last year todd howard said that they
were going to go back to their roots
that they went back to their roots
that's what this game was going to be
they're going to go back to their roots
make a game
like they used to make
uh so they went over a little bit of
features in in star field
game character origin stats
and uh are important so that's what i
was saying that they're going to let you
build your character put the stats and
whatever you want to so if you want to
put stats in and small arms you could
put stats and small arms if you want to
put stats and
whatever they have for energy weapons
you can put stats in energy weapons if
you want to put stats in a big ass
hammer you go around hitting people with
you could put stats in that
uh and that that's really important to
me i feel like that is the core
foundation of their games and i was
really disappointed that wasn't in
fallout 4.
all right now let's
character origins which
this is kind of weird
because they've never really done this
character do you know what character
origins are hustle no all right so
but by the sound of it it means like you
get to pick your birth mother birth
father is that no like like where you're
from okay
the way that i think this is now
obviously
i could be interpreting this differently
than it actually is
did you ever play like the
the dragon
age games or anything like that
nah that was not from my thing either
well at the beginning of the dragon age
games it whatever race you pick
your origins is with their people
oh okay okay i got you so if you were
like a war well this is like kind of
like a warrior class or
yeah yeah no i understand okay that now
i understand
i'm hoping that's how what they're
saying here
because they did bring up multiple
factions so it would be cool
if whatever race you pick up with
their origin starts in their in their
home country or their home planet or
something related to that i don't know
exactly what it would be but i i like
that they're doing something like that
because it's interesting it's
interesting
uh then they brought up
uh different in-game starts for
backgrounds
i don't really know what they mean by
that
like different end game starts for
background so maybe maybe factions like
you do an in-game start
i don't know
i don't know no no no okay i think when
they say different in-game um
wait stats or starts you mean like it'll
start off so it sounds like if they got
five different
origins that you can pick from it'll
have five different intros like
cyberpunk i believe had three different
intros
from streetcare
business person corporal whatever into
the other one see but that that kind of
that's what that sounds like that kind
of follows under the origins
yeah but i mean but just based off of
what you just told me that's kind of how
how i take that like was just based off
what you told me so you'll have five
different
openings it sounds like you wanna have
five different openings to me or a few
different openness to know how many
character classes they have if anyone in
the chat knows exactly what they mean by
that sentence uh
hit me up man uh tag
at iron lord's podcast i'm on the iron
lords podcast account today and and tell
me what you feel like you know we got
155 people in here
uh definitely that like button man let's
get it over to 100 likes before the end
of the podcast
uh
for those of you that are getting here i
know you know we've been going up uh
i don't normally like switching days but
we are discussing the possibility of
making the podcast on a wednesday
because i feel like it works out better
for everyone it could space me out a
little bit more from the iron lords
podcast uh so that that's good on there
and i felt like me mentally could do
wednesdays better uh but i do want to
hear the uh
the chat's opinion on the matter uh what
hey i don't got access to it but can you
just make a poll in the chat yeah sure
go ahead and talk while i do it
all right so but with everything that's
going on with starfield and as you guys
know i'm not that particular but that's
the fan i kind of want to get your
thoughts on it in the chat like
on a scale of 1 to 10 are you guys
excited for the new style field with the
news that we heard today that's my first
question
my second question is
for a newbie like me to get involved in
it
how do you suggest that i start playing
like how what do you suggest cause like
i'm just i'm playing um elden ring you
know this is like my second maybe third
even um
souls type game
and pretty much they told me start with
magic so is there a particular class
that i've made maybe i need to start
with if it's anything like elder ring
excuse me anything like elder scrolls or
anything like fallout
let me know in the chat
i
okay
i've always felt like these type of
games you need a root a route you you
need
something that you generally do at the
beginning of every game to build up your
character and then you get to that point
and then you branch out
you know what i'm saying like at fallout
new vegas
my route or route however you guys want
to say it in the comment section
is i went down the map around it and i
went to uh to
to new vegas and then in new vegas
that's when i would establish some form
of base
and then i would branch out and do
things from there skyrim is a little
different
i usually change things up in skyrim
quite often i don't know why i love
skyrim though probably one of my
all-time favorite games
it that that's that's what i would
recommend on on star field
just getting a good feeling on what you
want to do because they're gonna this
could be a hardcore rpg
so
i'm hoping that you know that works out
well and for those of you that noticed
my voice is definitely going away a
little bit
it's fine we got probably another 30
minutes i could last for 30 minutes uh
so here's the next one scans of real
models
a model like so pretty much like
they're they're spending some money man
they're they're making sure that they
scan real life objects in the game
hopefully that means that they're going
to stay stay away from like the
hand-drawn stuff like i don't know
problem with it skyrim was hand-drawn a
lot of that game was androne and that's
why it looks so particular uh but it
really does look like not i think this
is a double-edged sword what they're
doing here hustle would you not
safe to assume
where they're using scans of
uh you know quote-unquote real model
uh photography
would you not say that that might give
people expectations that the game's not
going to look gorgeous
yes when you say you're taking the time
to
use something real as opposed to
something that you can illustrate on
your own which yeah i mean like when you
say you're doing that of course i expect
i expect a higher level of what you were
originally doing in the first place like
when you say that when you say that to
me that means that means hey you're
going out like like forza forza horizon
for instance they would go out have like
the the high high expensive cameras yeah
i mean and take pictures of the clouds
just to get the clouds right yeah i mean
like so when you say that to me that's
this is initially what i think
so yeah i expect
a better level of quality in terms of
the game and i kind of might you know
maybe i just want to check it out just
for that because i i had no idea that
that was this i didn't have a chance to
look over this uh
this over um almost skyrim over the
starfield stuff almost i didn't have a
chance to look over it but now i kind of
want to see now you're kind of picking
my interest a little bit do i you make
me want to check it out day one i'ma
have game pass anyway so you kind of
make me want to check it out day one man
you know
you got game pass you're trying this out
day what you know there's no way you
don't there's no way we'll see
we'll see there's zero percent chance
you don't try this game day one may all
you have to do is just click download
especially you know that's going to be
on pc
it's going to be it'll take no time but
it's going to take no time for me so
yeah you need to just go ahead and pull
that trigger and get an xbox series x
that's what you need to do so wait a
minute wait a minute and then i know
we're talking about the starfield stuff
i am going to get a series s or series x
rather i'm going to serious x i just got
gotta make sure i can find them joints
when i'm because i can't have my phone
on me at work no more so i can't
like normally it's easy like oh i get i
see it at best buy i try to go get it as
soon as i can but i'm gonna do my best
to have this i got ps5 sitting up here
all the sitting up on my my setup all
alone man you're all alone
we'll have to talk to someone
see forte can help you out with that
next time one pops in maybe he could
hit you up see if you want it yeah i let
him know i saw a hell out of my
highlander shout out before table we got
a five dollar shipper from space dover
king
i think their confidence is sky high and
that's why they're hyping this game up
like crazy and i believe them they look
seriously confident they do
if you look at them in that trailer
they really do look like they got like
they know they got the baddest chick at
this this next dance like
they really be looking like that you
know i'm right also like they'd be
looking like they about to go in here
and you ain't gonna be able to do
nothing to to fight that
it's interesting man it's interesting
all right so then the persuasive system
with npcs
trying for a more realistic human to
human dialogue it's a very interesting
way they put this if if i remember
correctly they say when you're
arguing with someone
they wanted to feel like an actual
conversation with a person
and they don't want one option to be
that this is clearly the good this is
clearly the bad they want that thing
where you're generally looking at those
conversations
and
you don't know what they're going to
react to with it
how you feel about
sentences like that because i feel like
that's a huge thing to come out and say
that you're going to
try your hardest to have
the most
realistic human conversations that you
can do
when you tell me that
the first game that came to my mind was
uh and i'm sure you guys remember like
l.a noire so you remember you guys were
cold and when you interrogated people
you had either the truth
a lie or doubt it sounded like to me
that most of that stuff would seem a lot
more natural so when let's just say
everything's doubt you don't know it's
almost like you don't know
that well hold on well almost what we do
know is that these answers won't be as
heavy-handed as as like previous
iterations of other rpgs that uh
bethesda has put out that that to me is
dope and if they if they know something
like that then like that you're kind of
selling me on this a little bit i know
that's what the whole point of that
thing was today but it's kind of selling
me on
the idea of this like i said i'm not no
no but there's the cat like that but it
really makes me want to check that out
but if you can get that down down pat
and what the last thing is you making
things more realistic and then you pull
it off then i never hate on that hey i'm
addict side note so i know
i know a guy whose brother works at
bethesda he does like the i think he
does like the mocap and stuff like that
i used to work at a
i can't say where i used to work out
virginia
and i bumped into this guy and we
started talking about like you know we
actually talked about the last of us he
said hey my brother works
so i'm like okay well how was it over
there he was like yo
he he said it's a trip and a half
working over there but there's the man
there that's super dope i'm gonna try to
reach back out to him and see if we can
try to get him on but like that that to
me is like super dope man i i hope this
game kind of turns out well because you
seem like you up on it you really seem
like you're excited doing it that and a
lot of people in chat do too
i think
people
look
it's gonna be different with starfield
because it's a new ip
and i don't think people are really
taking in
how
how big it is to have bethesda games
exclusive to the microsoft platform and
obviously on pc it's not exclusive you
get what i'm saying like oh yeah yeah
yeah but but hustle
when that eldon re when that not elder
when that elder scrolls six drops
and that sucker says only on xbox and pc
people that's going to hit people hard
because
especially if
i think todd howard retires after that
game i think that's his last game
and
and i think he gonna make sure that game
comes out and does what it's supposed to
we gotta fight all this super chat from
dawn otaku
i'm calling the game of the year
rankings now
one
breath of the wild two two comes out
elden ring three star filled
for
god of war ragnarok five
horizon forbidden west
and the real number one
kirby baby you don't be crazy if kirby
actually won that no i meant to bring
this up earlier when you would ask me
what games i was excited for i got to
get home i got to find my switch and get
the connections and stuff right
i want to play that game i lowkey want
to play i've been playing kirby
superstar like behind the scenes a
little bit yo that game is still on
super nintendo that game's still fun i'm
not going to hold you that game is like
super fun but i i kind of want to do i
definitely want to play the kirby game
man i want to hear like from like the
nintendo fans like a player essence like
a blind drew i want to i kind of want to
hear from them what they really think
about like that in particular but
kirby man it's well here one thing that
we know for sure about that it's going
i'll sell metroid prime or metroid dread
so metroid but anyway yeah
all right so let's go over the
a little bit more of the information
they went um they did
say that they really
do an emphasis on companions the people
that work with you in the game
and it showed a big ass robot like
so clearly that's gonna be one of the
companions i don't know
what his deal is
and what i really want to interest is
like the factions they do look like
they're going back to the to the
factions type of system that was in
fallout new vegas obviously that was
made by obsidian
but it's interesting that they're going
to do that
and they they talked about space pirates
they talked about
a society that
is kind of like
wild wild west
they talked about like
pretty much like a galactic
like place like like you know like in
every
type of star wars or you know those
those
space
non-fictions that they have that one
thing that controls the whole
like galaxy like that one
they kind of hinted at them too they did
like a little bit in terms of
um
a like a trade thing as well like a
trade so uh a trade service or something
like that some kind of convoy i don't
know
but
the game looks good man and like look i
get it
i get it
we don't know nothing about it
but here's the thing hustle
do you know when skyrim was announced
like no it was announced december of
2010
do you know when that game came out
when it november 11th
of 2011
yes
okay
do you know when fallout was announced
fallout 4
no
e3 of the year came out
yeah well with the five months before
the game came out
yeah they'll they'll do that they'll do
stuff like that
i'm pretty sure some of their other
games like doom and stuff that they
same thing
so it's just like look
are you hating on starfield
because you're generally concerned and
you don't have any information on it
or are you hating on starfield because
maybe not necessarily you don't want to
succeed but you don't like the hype the
game's getting
i don't know i feel like if you was
paying attention you would clearly see
that this is bethesda's mo
so why is so many people
going above and beyond attic it's
getting delayed
addict it's it's it's looking like
people are actually saying this game
looks like cyberpunk
oh wow
is everything going to get a cyberpunk
effect these days
just because
not every studio gotta act the same
bethesda is known for this
so why we acting like this is new this
is not
new and i guess
i want to respond to something in the
chat a z black writer i just saw your
last comment um
but that's the show game play but
they'll show it like six months before
the joint drop like we i've seen that i
do remember saying that because that you
bring up a great point i remember seeing
that with doom and i want to say it was
wolfenstein but i was like well damn
they ain't wasting no time i remember
saying that at a3 that was like all
right we're going to show you this and
then we're going to drop it in november
or whatever it was yeah so they
that that kind of has been a thing
recently and i've always appreciated it
about them but i'm just not i'm not
doing cats so you know it is but
it's just you know they just don't make
titles that particularly appeal to me
but if you know and addict i think i
don't know if it was you who said it
maybe it was king i was like oh they're
going to show their joint when they
would say oh somebody's one of one of us
on that panel said hey they didn't show
anything i was like let's see now
they're gonna wait till next year and
they're gonna drop it they said they're
gonna do what they've been doing
yeah but see i don't remember saying
that i didn't like that because i do
feel like
they announced this in 2018.
we he deserved gameplay last year we did
like welcome
i feel like
you hyped let's be real here hustle they
hyped the hell out of that conference
for starfield these acted like dave's
about to show everything about starfield
and we get that little weak trailer at
the beginning and i know
they needed star field to be there
because they wanted to show the unity
between bethesda and microsoft that was
their first e3 starfield had to have
been there but it's like cool down
talking about star field
every time you bring up starfield you
get excited about star field and then
people get upset with me
because i'm being excited about star
field now
it's just like they should have showed
more last year uh you know obviously
we're a couple months away from e3 at
this point well whatever their
equivalent of e3 is going to be
so we're we're about to see it it's
going to be real soon
you're quite i'm putting you on the spot
right now hustle you're going to be in
the iop reaction to the microsoft
conference
uh assuming if it's on sunday for sure
because i don't have to work that day um
yeah i mean they do usually do so i hate
that [ __ ] too man i can't you know what
it is
things are so different now like let's
put it this way if i can be here for
sure for sure i'll be here um
yeah if oh one thousand percent i'll be
there but it's you know things are so
different now with how everything's
being rolled out and pushed out
uh it'll probably be a pre-recorded
thing too um that would which is an
important thing because we saw a
playstation do that with like the
future regaining thing i think a lot of
these things will be pre-recorded none
of these things will be live anymore
because there's no need for that um
i will be there if it's on a sunday
uh anytime after 4 pm hey i'm in the
house at that point as long as i don't
have to be nowhere of course i'll be
here my only concern is man look
can they have a camera that look like
mine can they have a lens that looks
like looks like mine or yours yes
now i know it was on point last time but
just make just keep it up i will keep it
up i will say that i think one of the
reasons they was looking so sketchy all
the time was because
at that time
i think that they were
they they were in like in and out if
they were gonna do like is this pandemic
going to be this serious are we going to
be able to do an in-house show so i
don't necessarily know
if that was something that was on their
mind you know what i'm saying and then
you got to look like
aaron greenberg's camera looked rough
rough it was like a laptop camera
how do i got a better camera than this
man did like
but they they learned they sent that man
a camera
and you know what's crazy is
i would say i do think that some
something had to do with they were
transitioning from because that was at
the beginning of the pandemic they were
transitioning but it's like how did you
feel like
you doing first off how you doing
meetings on this aaron
that people can't even see you that well
how are you doing meetings i'm glad he
got that fixed like
you know microsoft
a trillion dollar company they got to
have cameras in a closet somewhere you
know what i'm saying like
like someone go to the office and get
some of those cameras out melding to
people man
like
even if the it's not that point these
people make
mad they make good money aaron you have
money to buy a camera
man
i like the
i like the energy area gives out but
that camera wasn't it man that camera
wasn't it all right
let's go to the main event
all right man uh the main event of
disappointment can we talk about it yeah
we obviously we got to keep it real man
we got to keep it right oh man
hustle
yeah the initiative
has lost the majority of its workforce
and the majority of its lead people
in the past 12 months
what is your initial thoughts when you
saw this
that you know oh let me stop shaking my
desk i noticed my camera shaker said
this
i'd
okay
i saw a video from oh no it's alex yeah
make sure you go subscribe to my man he
actually put no quality content
he pretty much had the comparison that
you remember when crystal dynamics was
announced that they were coming over to
help with the perfect dog project
a lot of people felt the way about it
and i had a feeling that they did i
really should have did a video on it but
oh well i had a feeling that they did
because i was in a situation like this
to where you pretty much have to train
your replacements
a lot of people not gonna be feeling
that so
anybody in their right mind myself
included get the hell up out of there
they you know they'll say hey you know
what you gave us a shout over here at
the initiative man
hey maybe things ain't working but i'm
gone so a lot of people left it to me is
is so
disheartening like i think one of the
narratives and i read part of that um
shout out to the finalists on twitter he
had sent it to me earlier today like one
of the narrative like leads had left and
when i saw it i said damn i'm like yo
the narrative like that's supposed to be
the big deal for me when it comes to
perfect talk we saw about this last week
and somebody last week i'm like yo i
said hustle why are you so excited for
it because that the story wow i like i
like the actual story but for the
knowing that one of the lead designers
one of the lead narrative people left as
well there's some programmers leave they
had a bunch they had a ton of people
leave that
this isn't like a halo thing right
remember how in halo we had heard
maybe one or two people who had left
and here's the thing in the gaming
industry people leave all the time we
just may not be privy to it but people
leave all the time they may find a
better opportunity with a better studio
et cetera et cetera so you talked to a
friend that recently
went to another company
from a different company
and he said addict you have no idea the
money being thrown around the industry
right now like get that bag like get
that bag
it's like look i will say when it comes
to the initiative
is looking pretty spooky the initiative
now there's a couple things i think i
made a video about this so anyone
watching
definitely go check that out uh we've
got five troops super chat from donna
taku we know damn well xbox marty team
get get crumbs
uh
look regardless if they get crumbs or
not
man like
a a 1080p camera like a hundred bucks
dollar taco like i mean they tell me
they can't afford that
i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure they spend that money
on dinner
they could have easily bought that now
i'm not i'm not gonna i'm not gonna go
too much into that you know we could
talk about it for a couple seconds i'm
not gonna go too much into that because
i do feel like
there was extreme circumstances to that
they just started a pandemic
um you know it probably slipped their
mind about the people need to remember
too
that i don't know if microsoft has like
equipment like that laying around
i'm pretty sure they would have
something like that but i don't know if
if if
if that if taking something from them
what from something else would hurt
somewhere else you know what i'm saying
uh it was probably just one of those
things where maybe aaron wasn't even
supposed to be in that inside xbox he
was put in it at the last minute
yeah
it's just like we don't know everything
going on there
aaron should have known better though he
should have looked at that camera and be
like oh no this ain't it like it's like
someone sent me a camera let me go to
walmart something like that should have
happened
yeah he gonna easily want the um he
could have easily got a pandas because i
used to use a panasonic g7 with this
lens that i'm using now now i got a sony
a6100 he could easily just went and just
used the kit lens on the joint but
that's just you know what that's just me
poking fun at something this is so long
ago but they've improved since then so
hopefully yeah they got it that's cause
we we we we went a little extra on man
we went a little extra at this because
look we we want we want them to do
better we want playstation to do better
we want xbox to do better and in a lot
of ways i want nintendo to do better
well we don't get that one addict but
let's let's get back to what um let's
get back to the topic
hey man
the perfect dog situation dog
to me because i am looking forward to it
that joint scared the hell out of me
because again we don't necessarily see
when people leave
but we never seen nobody in this type of
it's like a mass exodus damn there it's
a lot of people who left there's a whole
lot of people who love it i'm like damn
it's just like out of nowhere um i had
read that article from i think it was
vgc 247 i do believe that's where i read
it from
there's
it seems like there's a leadership issue
over there with the initiative and what
i mean by that is
they're so laid back over there it was
like you can get it done just take your
time but sometimes
i would love to tell people to take
their time and do the best possible
thing period but sometimes people need
to put up their ass people need
direction people need hey we got dates
to hit this thing this thing in this
thing sometimes you sometimes you need a
deadline i ain't saying crunch but i'm
saying sometimes you need a deadline and
it's good to have a deadline it's going
to have that type of structure and and
again man when when crystal dynamics
came in
a lot of people on the internet and i
want to maybe i want to include me maybe
i don't but a lot of people was like oh
this is just a move to buy um crystal
dynamics because david gallagher used to
be the league guy over there and all
that i don't think so man i don't think
so i think they well obviously they saw
like i don't know
i don't think anything
they wanted
i don't think it's a move to buy crystal
dynamics
but i do think
there was some creative differences
between the two
and i think maybe
yeah daryl gallagher
might have subconsciously
agreed to his old co-workers
because
it's it's been a huge drastic
change for like a year and i feel like
that's around the time crystal dynamics
probably showed up
because they just recently got announced
you know they didn't say that when it
first happened i'm not saying that
they're buying them i think they might
end up buying them especially now since
they lost it
i'm just saying that i feel like a good
reason that probably happened that
people aren't talking about is you got
people
at cr at crystal dynamics that had the
same title
as people added the initiative
i think people were feel like they were
getting their their voices heard i feel
like there's a lot of stuff going on
over there and
and look i'm not saying that that's
exactly what happened but i am saying
this is one of the only times we've ever
seen
a company or a developer such as biggest
crystal dynamics
helping
a first-party studio company as well
uh and it's just like
it's weird i'm not gonna say it's like
the end of the world
uh here's the thing microsoft owns 30
plus studios yes i'm counting the uh the
activision get the one there's no way
that doesn't get approved at this time
even the
the ceo of microsoft said he doesn't
think it's going to get blocked so
assuming that goes through
microsoft owns 30 plus studios if you
guys feel like 30 plus studios are gonna
be on that game 100 of the time you're
sadly mistaken there's gonna be some
there's gonna be some rebels in the in
the bunch there's just gonna be some
rebels in the bunch uh let me ask you
something though you don't think that
this speaks to
like like leadership i i said it before
but this this this kind of speaks to
leadership let me tell you why
leadership microsoft hold up one second
leadership to
the initiative or leadership to
microsoft
since no well to the initiative right
the initiative is the microsoft founder
studio as you know they created it they
built it they own it
however activision is something blizzard
that's something that's already in-house
uh the square i know they don't own
square but like these are already other
ones that are already in-house oh but
there's there's one that could run
itself so it does it seem it seems to me
it seems to me that they the microsoft
is cool they're buying the studios and
letting them run how they run with the
culture being the culture how it is with
with an activision well maybe that
activation with um
with the bethesda right let's use them
as an example but when it comes to their
own thing it's like they
it's like they don't know which way is
up in terms of like time management and
stuff like that so i it just it looks
bad it looks it looks bad for microsoft
this looks really bad for microsoft
for microsoft game studios but like for
uh matt booty and all the i look bad for
them knowing that all their people left
and they had to bring in crystal
dynamics to help
yeah it does yeah it looked bad yeah and
even at that time
if you go back and you look i'm sure we
did an attic show on that like
we said that back then like this isn't
this isn't normal like this doesn't
happen like this like
and
i feel like
does this speak bad on the initiative
yes uh clearly something needs to be
done over there i don't know if
clearly they're saying that might be a
soft reboot so they might have restart
the whole damn game you're going to
restart the game make it a third purse
cover game please for the love of god
make it a third-person cover stealth
action adventure game and while you
before you read that super check at it
while you add it get help from the
coalition god please please get home
get help from the coalition sir listen
to me sir don't listen to me sir
we we we don't need help from the
coalition
yes you do
okay
buy the ina buy crystal dynamics merge
them with the initiative because clearly
daryl gallagher needs to work with
crystal dynamics because he left the
company ends up bringing the company on
to help them
something's what that uh
so
you merge those two companies together
because
i i i personally feel like
like square enix don't want that company
anymore
like they're just like oh you're gonna
cost us money we're gonna pawn you off
on microsoft for a couple years go work
on perfect dark it's like it's like
they're being punished go work on
someone else's stuff
you're no longer uh able to work on your
own stuff
it's just like look if you can get that
from them
merge those studios together
and focus on making
a perfect dart that's a third person
because look we got a lot of first
person stuff michael so let's be real
here i'm not look i'm always
advocate on
i love first person stuff but we do got
a lot of third person stuff and cognito
if his fame is just one and like
forget just one let's have like three
four like you got 30 plus studios you
can easily make a couple now i'm not for
having a studio like obsidian make
i don't want to make it i want but that
is the software making i want i don't
want uh exile studios make it i don't
want none of the studios that i love
making a third person i want them to
make what they make because they make
those rpgs good but the coalition
they're making obviously they're making
gears then you have
um
you have compulsion making one
you have hell blade they're making uh
ninja theory's making hellblade uh you
know we need to make sure there's a
balance now as far as what's going on
with the initiative it looks bad on the
i'm not going i will say the initiative
needs something done to them now maybe
it's already being done we just don't
know it maybe it's maybe this has been
something in the works and they've
slowly started restructuring the way
that game goes because it wasn't go look
sometimes when stuff's happening
there's there's change of leadership's
going on and people just don't get along
i i know from experience of talking to
certain people when other people take
over it's not like working with your
friends anymore because your friends are
gone
so you leave
now i don't know that's going on here i
don't know i don't keep track of that
stuff and to be honest with you i don't
care about perfect dark game could get
canceled it wouldn't bother me so let's
go
what's up smith i don't know what he's
saying 100
of that but all right so
but as far as
first party studios
i don't think there's an issue there i
think 343 is having issues clearly uh
and i think a lot of that has to do with
with you know i think the game
such as halo came out a little bit hot i
don't think it was supposed to come out
the way it did i think you should have
been delayed and
when you're behind the eight ball on the
initial game obviously you're gonna be
behind the eight ball when the game
comes out
so i think they got stuff to do there
you know maybe they need to hire some
contractors and just make maps like they
need to hire in a whole team like a team
of 30 or 40. go out there remake the the
halo one two three and four maps
and let's get like 10 maps out by the
end of the season
that's what i would do if i was halo i'm
not i don't run studios like that either
so
it is what it is
uh kid smooth said he voted no look
smooth all right
i know the i know planet xbox is on
wednesdays all right
but i can assure you smooth
we will be done by eight to nine o'clock
we won't
let my dogs in sir yeah well you could
go let your dogs at any time that's fine
we're not going to step on planet xbox
all right
there's other podcasts i have no problem
stepping on
but i'm not stepping on your podcast
those are addicts words not mad i ain't
finished
look man
there's sometimes
your homie man
your close friend i ain't gonna
i ain't gonna put a podcast during your
time slot it's just i feel like it's
real
but thank god but when it comes to like
other podcasts
look
sometimes
it is what it is like i can't i can't
i can't schedule addicts show around
everyone's show then i would never have
a time slot
you know what the the funny thing is
because i guess we're going to wrap up
with this perfect dog topic anyway
the funny thing is i don't really see
anybody
during wednesdays like the only one the
only person who i see during wednesdays
but his time difference is different
from us is um dutch wandering dutch you
know but his time they they over across
the pond and all that so their time
difference is like way different they
come on like two o'clock
for like the midweek match up and all
that that might be the only one that i'm
aware of i could be wrong though and
that's what i'm saying like when it
comes to this
that's why i go early because i don't
want to step on anyone you know i do my
best to make sure everyone flourishes
like i really do
i don't want to step on people's
podcasts we go at 5 p.m you guys realize
i went to bed at 2.
i work nights sir
like so
i go above and beyond to make sure that
this podcast works for everyone so we're
probably going to move it to wednesday
at 5 p.m because i feel like that works
better for everyone but smooth i'm not
going to step on playing at xbox
so all right
let me go back before smooth derailed
the whole podcast i think that
bethesda's fine because bethesda knows
how to manage himself pretty well i
think activision's going to be fine
obviously because activision manages
itself pretty well and i think i think
matt booty's doing his job
now if the studio's matt booty is is
is supervising
start pushing out duds then maybe he
needs to be replaced i don't know uh
because i don't feel like we have enough
information we haven't had enough games
released to really have an opinion on
that
like yeah yeah that's too early
waistline came out highly rated sure
that wasn't
that wasn't directly under microsoft
only the telling of that was under
microsoft psychonauts same thing but
they still gave them money and time
to make these products better
so
until i see that quality drop
i'm not going to go out and say matt
booty's not doing his job when you have
30 plus studios some of them are going
to get behind on stuff some of them are
going to have uh you know
rocky development cycles not
everything's going to be perfect
especially when you keep
expanding your studios in your portfolio
you're going to have some people that
mess up it's just going gonna it's just
what it is hopefully
microsoft will correct the ship with 343
rare with everwild and the initiative
with whatever's going on i think the
initiatives best point of view is just
to stay low and try their hardest to get
crystal dynamics because i really do
also i really do feel like if they're
able to get crystal dynamics and merge
them i feel like that will solve a lot
of initiatives issues
uh regardless of the people leaving
people leave all the time now this is a
little bit more concerning because a lot
of people are leaving but it's a lot of
people but at the same time we got to be
realistic here we don't know what
happened behind closed doors on this and
we're missing a lot of variables for
instance we're
we're missing
what the relationship between crystal
dynamics and this place is but i will
agree with everyone
something needs to be done over there
i don't know what it is
i can't tell you i don't run a studio
but what i can tell you is what we're
seeing isn't normal
we're not people don't leave studios at
this high of a magnitude now maybe
maybe this is the original crew and they
started losing
people of the gauntlet and then they
didn't feel comfortable being there and
then there could be a power struggle
between chris the dynamics the
initiative
and crystal's winning so
because
crystal dynamics we got to keep in mind
crystal is
i'm not saying crystal
crystal sounds really crazy crystal
dynamics is a veteran studio that
probably
moves as a team way better than the
initiative does
so
they're probably going to be able to
contribute more than all the initiative
combined
because they they move as a team they've
been working on games well yeah and i i
am going to cut you off but yeah you
talk about like that's like a chemistry
thing it's like yo we know these people
so well like we know how each other's
gonna move in terms of everything like
you know it's just like what you and i
do like yeah things was a little shaky
in the beginning but things are
progressively over time getting a hell
of a lot better than they were from when
we first started so yeah that's gonna be
a thing man um
i'm gonna know how my brother's moving
you know
more than this other person over here
they're from from this other company
and you know whether it's intentional or
not like yo that is that's just a thing
like if the island would step somewhere
and you know you guys are let's say
with somebody else like yeah of course
y'all gonna have the chemistry to move
about because you've been around
yourself for so long so yeah so that's
definitely a thing as well um
i got a theory and i don't know how
maybe i sound crazy you tell me if i'm
bugging at it i feel like when you sign
on for a project you should stay for the
duration of that project and i kind of
feel like you should have to sign
paperwork behind that
unless maybe you weren't really bad
maybe what's up not make them sign
paperwork but
like
make them sign paperwork like look like
if you want to leave you can leave we're
not going to make you stay here
but upon completion of this project you
can get a nice bonus
and i think that they do that now right
do they though
we're always being told people getting
people getting gypped out of out of
bonuses and stuff
you know some
some companies tie bonuses like
metacritic store i don't know if that
stuff happens anymore but
it's just like
maybe if you offered people good money
to stay they would stay because i do
understand what you're saying from
when you have developers leaving mid
cycle you're going to have you're going
to have constant hiccups because that
person there
that was in charge of something in that
project he's gone now
so you're gonna have person showing up
you've got to be up to date on what's
going on sure they can promote with from
within but then that person
he was doing something before he got
promoted
so now that job's not being done it's
just a domino effect they need to be
better on that they need to be very
vocal with all their studios um i do
feel like maybe there might be a little
bit of
of control that's not being done
microsoft
needs to get a good balance in terms of
we're going to be lingered with you
there's a difference between creative
freedom
and freedom
they're giving them too much freedom but
they still have creative freedom
just because you have creative freedom
does not mean you can't meet deadlines
facts yeah that was one of the things i
said in the very beginning like yo you
that's cool that you got that type of
freedom but you got to have
you got to have like these stop gaps and
you got to meet these goals
to the ultimate goal which is finishing
the game and make sure it's coming out
good
maybe microsoft's being a lot more
lingual on these first games coming out
because
they know they're important i would say
that all these games have very huge
criteria that microsoft needs to hit out
the gate
and maybe they're being so lenient with
them they're like look
push out halo a year later this still
came out but
microsoft can't keep delaying the game
forever
um halo infinite was definitely a game
that needed more time but i wouldn't say
it was an incomplete game it was a game
that had that was missing features
but i feel like an incomplete game and a
game missing features are two different
conversations
and it is what it is they need to do
better over there and i hope they do
better because
microsoft at the top of their game
pushes sony to do stuff they wouldn't
normally do pushes nintendo to do stuff
they won't normally do we need more of
that man
but
anything last you want to say about the
perfect dart situation man because it's
looking real hard over there hustle
um
yeah actually yeah i do i think the
perfect character for a joanna dark
redesigner is ruby soho who's a wrestler
over there aw if you know you know
i kind of
feel like she can be there also
look they've made third-person games
before if you really gonna flip it make
it a third-person game but if you're not
like yo addict when we talk like when
the narrative design leaves like yo it's
a reboot you can just retell the first
story so like that's stuff like that
kind of
as you were talking i just thought about
it yo if it's a reboot then you already
got the story that's there but i don't
know man actually
i
people have this narrative that the
initiative is like
the engine
and they work with another studio to be
like the crew
oh okay
like they like
after crystal dynamics their next game
they parked with another team and that's
cool if that's actually what's happening
here i i i kind of i'm very skeptical on
that opinion because i feel like if
that's what was happening here there
would be no reason for these people to
leave the initiative to leave because
they know that
if there is an issue between crystal and
the initiative
they would they're leaving after this
game why would you leave i i don't i
don't buy that like i feel like there's
a lot of a lot of speculation going on
but no solid proof to back those those
claims up
but hell of a support studio that'd be
like a super lit support studio yeah i
wouldn't but i wouldn't sign up for that
either though to keep it real with you i
wouldn't sign up for that but that's
that's just me that's just me um what's
up man
yeah i do
but if that if that isn't true
and they do this soft reboot and they
rebuild the initiative
maybe that's something you should look
at because i feel like that's unique
imagine partnering with a new studio
every
time you make a game you have a fresh
perspective but the thing is something
like that's never been done so you're
gonna have to find a good middle ground
because if the initiative has leads
in whatever studio they work with has
leads there's gonna be a lot of clashing
like it's gotta be one of those things
where the initiative is like this is the
game i want i don't care what the other
people have to say we'll take input we
might change things because we like what
they say but we can't change drastic
features of games because the company
that's making it doesn't want and they
don't feel like it's good for them we
got five dollar super trap from dawn
otaku delayed gains from them won't
matter by next year when they have too
many games ready and they have to initia
uh internally delay certain games to
make room i agree there's going to be a
point where that's happening 100 agree
yep
so i think that's pretty much all we got
man and you know this week's been a
little bit better on news uh
we we had some little juicy news man
hopefully hopefully next week we got
good good good news not bad news
uh
it's one of those things but we got to
talk about it it is it is what it is
my my saying is if microsoft don't want
us talking about the troubles of the
initiative
then they should make sure there's no
trouble with that initiative
so hustle what's what's going on man you
still streaming like
tell the realm
what's going on with you this week
i am still streaming and the second or i
have a job i'm transferring from one job
to another one the second net
settles itself out i will be streaming a
hell of a lot more often than doing the
show on wednesdays as well nothing
should change i think my hours are still
the same so i can tell y'all that that's
not a problem
um
elder ring this weekend
friday i'm gonna take a nap whatever i'm
wake back up i'm being this joint green
screen shouting i got i got got a new
light yeah yeah no no no i noticed
during the podcast my camera keeps
shaking right i'm gonna get the elgato
ring
like i need
you you look a little blown out but
that's fine because you can you can just
curl one of your lights and give you a
dramatic shadow effect
my camera where it is it just keeps
shaking but um i'm gonna get an elgato
ring light and hopefully
the it'll be a hell of a lot more stable
i'm right now i'm just using the uh old
ring light and that's just what it is
it's um
it's cool to be back it's cool to be
back and to be able to create content
and everything um
i look forward to streaming a lot more
at least three times a week hopefully
it'll be monday
not wednesday but it'll be like monday
thursday saturday something like that
i'll figure that out i will figure that
out on my own but i look i definitely
look forward to streaming more i'm
coming back with the youtube videos too
i didn't say i didn't want to say
nothing right up right now because i
kind of want to figure out what i want
to do but it probably won't be news
based since we covered the new stuff
here so i kind of want to be able to do
something different oh also
the reason why i asked you to end that 7
30. um i'll probably do a probably make
a wrestling channel in the very near
future
yeah yeah i'm rocking with aew i'll be
about but i've been rocking aw since
nice little minute now so i've been
keeping up with it so i kind of want to
do wrestling reviews and i don't think i
want to put it on my channel i think i
want to make a separate one for that so
i got all that stuff going i'm gonna get
some graphics and i'm gonna pay for all
that and do time
sometimes she'll be kind of lit and i
should be very busy let's just put it
that way but thank y'all thank you all
for joining me hey i'm real quick at it
can we uh
drop kids moves uh channel right here so
that you know so they can go ahead pull
up on smooth when when planet xbox comes
on tonight yeah let's move if you're
still in here it's playing the xbox
coming on the next i think you missed
last week
yeah um
you know
last week was a was a bad week uh you
know
give a little bit of a uh you know we we
lost a huge person in the community
californic network
uh
very positive dude and what i like about
him is i feel like we have too much
i want to be positive about everything
going around i don't ever want to talk
negative about stuff
and i feel like cal is always a good
mixture of both like
is the difference between
being positive and just trying to hope
for a good a
good outcome of a situation
and
putting enforcing positivity on every
situation
and i feel like sometimes people
do the ladder a little bit like
there could be
good situations that happen without
feeling like you have to force it on
people but you know that is what it is
uh you know
rest a peace the cow he was a great dude
and he'll definitely be missed
uh
talked to the dude like a week ago man
playing out of the ring and that's the
last time i talked to him
all of a sudden man um he's actually the
reason and i before we edit can you get
a level one's information he's the
reason how i know about fame flow hugger
dallas and baron over there uh at level
one and
i don't know like i i've seen kyle with
in fact yo i think he was the reason i
found out about his move too because
wasn't smooth over there with them and
once upon a time or am i wrong oh my
getting him confused with somebody else
actually we was over that one point of
time with him too
yup yes i mean so he he's
given i was a giving birth but he he's
definitely one of the ones who have
assisted a lot of people in their
journey man and
i mean he'll be missed like that's not
it's it's never easy when when one of
our people like passes away because it's
always gonna
hit us a little harder than usual
it's gonna hurt um
from what i understand he left behind
the wife and the child so away from the
young child so that's that's never easy
i hate that man and what what i will say
we messy 24 7. this community messy 24
7. it never ends
um
and it's been that way since pretty much
i came into the community i think it was
like 2014 like heavy into the community
we got a five dollar super chat from don
otaku most of the best games i played
had dev issues so i don't care until the
game is released
definitely understand that man
definitely understand that uh but
when there's something serious happens
with this community
people people put that stuff to the side
for the most part and i respect that you
know we we we might be messy with each
other 24 7 we are we really messy but
when it comes to like serious stuff like
real life stuff
i do see the majority of the community
put that aside but anyway
as of right now
i don't know if we're going to be
wednesday next week uh talk a little bit
more i do got to talk to cognito too
because obviously it's on the channel um
i don't think he's going to have an
issue if i want to move it to wednesday
but i appreciate everyone for coming
through man keep in mind we are doing an
iop community night hustle you are
welcome if we play a game that's more
than four people um right now it seems
like the the
the poll choices on twitter is going to
be
wwe which i don't know why
i don't know why you guys want us to
play this game so damn bad
it's good but it's been requested like
five times
because how it's going is if you're a
member of the channel
you're picking the games we're picking
four of those games that we feel
comfortable playing and we're gonna let
the rest of twitter of our audience the
twitter choose between those games
so we got wwe
which i'm not looking forward to that
but wwe
then we got among us which i think a
good game of among us would be fun and
then
halo and
um
and overcooked
so those are the four games that's gonna
go on the chat uh on the poll i'll
probably do that after this podcast
uh so you know curious what you guys
have to say in the comments section what
you think we should play uh put it in
the comment section uh after the podcast
but you know thanks for everyone coming
through here man we had up to like 170
180 people
especially since we switched days that
that's really good that means a lot of
you really mess with us
yeah because i feel like that's the
majority of our viewership was that uh
yeah but like i said we're going to be
taking the artwork we're going to be
updating the next couple weeks
i think you guys are gonna like what i
have going for man i think you guys are
gonna like it but until next week
on a wednesday or tuesday i don't know
yet probably wednesday but we're going
we're gonna get there eventually man
work with us
this is addict and hustle we're out